so let's delve a little deeper into some
of today's retail updates with and
Rafael Stella columnist at Bloomberg
gadfly so Andreo before we go into the
specifics there's been some quite strong
numbers across the piece was this a last
splurge before a tougher 2017 that
definitely seems to be what it will be
this could well be the last hurrah we've
got warnings of inflation taking up
prices going up if that runs ahead of
wage growth consumer spending power
could well be squeezed and they could
reign in purchases now is just spending
being driven by consumer borrowing by
and large there's been lots of flapping
recently about the level of consumer
debt in the economy starting to rise
again that does look as if it's being
the case and there are all these dire
warnings about closing prices going up
electricals prices going up it looks
like consumers heeded those and they
purchased now before those price rises
and some of that will have been on
credit well let's go into the specifics
now I mean John Lewis probably the
standout story clearly they're finding
it a little tougher than they thought
let's hear what Charlie Mayfield
suggests that we've started to see some
inflationary pressure creeping into
pricing in a few areas but overall it's
been pretty muted so far and going
forward it's it's really quite uncertain
as to where what happens and what we do
know is that sterling is is twenty
percent weaker so there will be
inflationary pressure the cost price is
coming through are going to be are very
likely to be higher the big question is
how much of that gets absorbed by
retailers and how much gets passed on to
the customer my view is a lot will get
absorbed by retailers because we're in a
very intensely competitive market but to
be honest even if it gets passed on to
the customer that's not a great thing
either because it means that you know
prices are higher disposable income is
lower and demand suffers and that's not
good for retail either so either which
way no weaker sterling isn't great for
retail so so Johnny Mayfield of John
Lewis Partnership they're clearly rather
nervous about 2017 yes and he's right to
Bay with the inflationary pressure
coming through the other thing to
remember is John Lewis has been
expanding very well online its online
sales have really been grown and that
comes with a cost is the cost of getting
the deliveries to consumers homes and
also in
testing in infrastructure so it's not
just a market issue if you want to keep
up with consumers trends you have to
spend what about Waitrose they were
cutting prices very aggressively all the
way through the autumn some of their
rivals were saying to me privately they
thought it was a bit bit of panics Matt
could possibly be white rose has been a
great performer over the last few years
it did dip we've had a change of
management it's got to get itself back
on track well I guess the most positive
story today was marks and spencer done
really well best figures in general
merchandise home and clothing for six
years what's behind that well they had a
terrible Christmas last year so the
comparisons were very easy you know
they've have been sort of really turning
round trying to turn around the business
with price parts better styles going
back to their core customer but they
also had some help with the timing of
the way their year-end fell because they
could an extra five days and that
contain the winter sale big days of sale
was that flat of that top line but they
haven't been discounting as much as a
lot of people thought they might do so
the pricing is sharper the pricing is
definitely shopping what they're trying
to go for is this sort of bye-bye once
you know by first time round the price
is right you don't have to take it back
to week later because they're twenty
percent off and that does seem to have
worked seems like customers were
trusting the prices a bit more and they
didn't do that friday either they did
their own sort of promotions but they
avoided that and it really does seem to
work for them makes the figures from
next last week look even more dismal now
doesn't it that's right because it was a
it was the same patron next next don't
discount for Christmas either but it
seemed they lost out to rivals who did
discount so the picture with discounting
is is rather confusing the other thing
to remember is next has been a really
good performer for a lot of years mls is
sort of coming back from a poorer
situation it's in a recovery phase so
you have to contrast those two what
about tesco Tesco rough they won market
share and yes you know share price
reaction was pretty mad I thought Tesco
was mildly disappointed
actually they seem to have good momentum
going into Christmas but over that final
Christmas periods that really did seem
to wane and they've blamed it on
non-food they didn't do a promotion that
they did last year their food sales are
still pretty strong whereas Sainsbury's
Bruce nails were weaker but it's still a
war rave investors have really been
betting on this turnaround of texto if
there's any disappointment there that
that's not gray cantering through some
of the others debenhams again did better
than expected recently changed the CEO
surprisingly yeah there you go she has
erupted five-and-a-half percent today
yeah I think that could be slightly
eleuthera they they they very big in
beauty and beauties been a real standout
category so I think they benefited there
from rolling back on clothing any of the
others are stood out I mean bucket for
me was a really strong performance to
get now owner of bhajans and lon dis of
course it's been a great performer
because share price has actually
outperformed Apple over the last five
years it's been a really fantastic
performer a real unsung hero of of the
grocery sector